[Music]
the telescope was invented by a dutch
optician four centuries ago
before that it was believed the earth
was the center of everything
the theory that it actually revolved
around the sun was discounted
in the hands of italian astronomer
galileo the telescope brought reality
into focus
[Music]
modern telescopes are light years ahead
of those early versions and through
their eyepieces the universe continues
to unfold
a reflecting telescope bounces and
concentrates light with mirrors
production begins with the machining of
cylindrical metal parts
these are baffles and when screwed
together they'll block stray light that
would interfere with the telescope's
operation
more tools transform a solid aluminum
disc into a ring with spokes
this part called the spider is a
framework for supporting the telescope's
secondary mirror
after coating the metal parts with the
protective oxide they plunge them into a
vat of black dye
the dye soaks into the oxidized pores
and seals the surface of the parts
[Music]
next this molded disk of thick low
expansion glass will become the
telescope's primary mirror
a diamond edge tool rotates on a
calculated tilt to make the glass
slightly concave
to improve the concave profile a worker
coats the glass with abrasive he adds a
weight to a precisely curved cast iron
disc and spins it
the weighted iron disc bears down on the
abrasive coated glass to fine tune its
curvature
a worker then examines the finely ground
surface for scratches and using a
calibrated gauge he measures the radius
of the disc to confirm that the concave
profile is precisely what it needs to be
the glass now spins while a cylindrical
cutter aims dead center to cut out a
hole this center hole is sized to
accommodate the baffles we saw earlier
and it will also enable the mirror to be
held securely in the telescope
next the glass disk oscillates as an
automated tool rubs a compound against
it to polish it
a worker then applies some of the
compound onto a polishing disc and works
the surface of the glass against it
repeatedly
this hand polishing improves the surface
considerably in the laboratory a
technician compares the primary mirror
glass to a grid to verify that the
dimensions are accurate
he aims a laser at the glass
a computer analyzes the reflected light
if the angle is off by one thousandth of
the width of a hair the telescope's
image could be blurry
the glass is now ready for its mirror
finish
they lock it face down in a vacuum
chamber
they add small amounts of titanium oxide
silicon monoxide and aluminum
they close the chamber tightly encasing
the contents and then pump out most of
the air creating a partial vacuum inside
they activate a 6000 volt electrode
this sparks a glowing discharge of ions
onto the now rotating glass disc
these ions blast any lingering
contaminants from the glass to give it a
serious cleaning
they heat the aluminum titanium and
silicon pellets which evaporate into a
cloud of vapor
atoms condense landing on the surface of
the glass to form a glossy mirror
surface it takes just minutes for this
highly reflective coating to be applied
this telescope mirror is now ready to
reflect light from the stars and planets
in the sky
next a technician screws lenses into the
metal housing for the primary mirror
he adds a mount mechanism for the
eyepiece complete with knobs for
focusing
[Music]
he flips over the assembly and slides
that precision-made mirror onto the
housing
a cork ring cushions the mirror so a
retaining ring can be installed without
a scratch
the telescope's primary mirror is now
secured to the housing
he pieces together the three-part baffle
then screws it to the lens holder
protruding from the center of the
telescope mirror
he joins the baffle and mirror assembly
to the telescope tube the tube has
already been equipped with a secondary
mirror that will bounce reflected images
from the primary mirror back for
magnification and viewing
it's taken about six weeks to build this
telescope and now it's ready to help
unravel the mysteries of the universe
[Music]
you